neuf équipes mixtes ce jour là de deux
coureurs qui partent pour un relais de
80 tours la course à l'américaine
une course de frottement l'américaine
c'est comme une course aux points sauf
qu'une course aux points par équipe par
équipe de deux coureurs qui fait que ça
va beaucoup plus vite puisqu'en fait il
ya un coureur qui se repose pendant que
l'on trouve la faune donc en fait c'est
des courses qui roule à 50 à l'heure
pendant quelques mois dans le peloton
des amateurs des membres de l'équipe de
france de piste et un triple champion du
monde de la discipline
morgan kneisky surtout là pour vous
trouver ses repères
c'est important parce que il faut
reprendre un peu le contact des courses
en peloton généralement on s'entraîne on
est seulement entre couarde équipe de
france là il ya des des autres
paramètres d croira voilà à maîtriser
donc
donc c'est vrai qu'on s'est mis quelques
petits handicaps au niveau du matériel
pour pas écrasé la course entre
guillemets une course de stratégie sur
une distance de 50 kilomètres des points
à glaner tous les 5 km une épreuve où
même les sprinteurs peuvent s'essayer
c'est déjà une épreuve beaucoup plus
longue que ce que moi j'ai l'habitude de
faire moins en règle générale 3 voire 4
tours ça mais ça me suffit j'en profite
vraiment pour ça pour faire voilà des
courses qui sont vraiment différentes de
celles que moi j'ai l'habitude de faire
lassé des courses plutôt de fond qu'on
appelle sur la piste donc voila moi j'ai
besoin de faire des courses comme ça
pour pouvoir travailler à autre chose
que ce que je fais tous les jours c'est
à dire du second la stratégie c'était
ben de je faisais un peu les sprints et
quentin faisait le dernier et au final
ça a bien marché vu que quand tu as
gagné le dernier sprint et moi j'en ai
gagné à et je me suis placé sur
plusieurs sprints une stratégie gagnante
pour le binôme cette deuxième édition
était dédiée à maturité belle jeune
cycliste décédé en octobre dernier
coupe d'hiver épisode 3 au vélodrome
prévu au mois de janvier